well you seem pretty laid-back are you
laid-back are you kind of the strict one
like I'm definitely strict I am - oh
yeah I was raised by a very me too
strong single mother who's me - yeah
yeah German and yeah yeah but yeah yeah
it's tough because I have now I can
provide at one point it was extremely
challenging and it's hard for my mother
so I'm like really stoked like my first
skateboard I like pride and joy you know
and now like I give everything like I'm
like but at the same time you know
that's the that's the thing my husband
talked about we grew up with like
nothing and then when you have kids
you're like how do I get this like
what's proper I know that's a struggle
but your daughter Lola
she's 12 right yeah she's 12 and did she
start dating yet or no can I tell you
that I have way worse my daughter keeps
coming home some boy named Bo I'm gonna
have to beat kids like like and she's
five man I'm screwed yeah she not into
boys yet if she's still like it yeah no
okay no but I feel sorry for this I mean
it can be fun when the boy does an all
and just grunt don't say anything it's
like let's just say grunt out of anyway
[Laughter]
what do you kids think of you as Aquaman
though really when they sell the movie
is that kind of cool for them cuz
they're so young and really getting into
that was perfect I mean they grew up
with Justice League so they got a you
know where the tiara from I mean he was
obsessed with Batman well if he was so
he gets to wear everything and be in the
Batmobile and but yeah and the first
time I saw it I actually waited cuz I
want to see what my babies and so we
went to the premiere and saw together
and excited wolfies extremely emotional
and so like when I'd get hurt or beat up
he'd be like crying and I'm my buddy
Papa's right here
sorry but we don't have we don't have
team we don't have TV Anglophones or add
stuff so like we don't good yeah just
because the little imaginations are
growing it's like let them have that day
of the rest of your life to watch all
these great you're a good dad okay I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this